Democrats lay out an insanely extreme
agenda to culturally divide the country
the NBA caves to the Communist Chinese
government and Democrats target Rudy
Giuliani's associates I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben
Shapiro show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressvpn dot-com / Ben alrighty so let
us begin with a basic truth all the
Democrats had to do was not be insane
that's it that's all they had to do I've
been saying this since the day of the
election of 2016 all Democrats would
have to do is not be crazy if they
wanted to defeat Trump in 2020 they did
not have to be exceedingly forth going
they didn't have to be really winning
they didn't have to be very exciting all
they had to do was not be bat bleep
loony that's it all they had to do was
bid not his beat not totally insane
naturally Democrats have been unable to
do that and so we have seen Democrats
not only go insane over things like the
Mobil report but on policy they've been
swinging radically to the left and
that's not just true on things like
Medicare for all well frankly there's a
pretty healthy debate in the country
over exactly which direction we should
go with our national medical system
should it be more regulated you to be
less regulated Medicare for all happens
to be a controversial topic but that is
at least within sort of the realm of
traditional American discussions been up
for debate since at least the 1990s when
Hillary care was discussed Democrats
have decided that they are going to go
all-out crazy on social leftist issues
and this is where you get into the
issues the kind of issues that divide
Americans beyond all recognition if you
were on the country to actually divide
all you have to do is keep putting your
thumb directly in the social issues and
just pushing that's all you have to do
because there are certain principles
that Americans are not going to
compromise on and if Americans are
forced to choose between adherence to
religious principle adherence to moral
principle what they teach their children
and the dictates of the social left they
will stand with their own religious and
moral principles and if they are
castigated as bigots they are still not
going to cave to the social left they're
not going to cave to the Editorial Board
of the New York Times or the anchors at
CNN they're not going to cave to the
board members at the Human Rights
Council the Human Rights Campaign who
tell them that their attendance at
church and their teaching
scripture to their children or teaching
their children traditional natural law
principles vacuum behavior that this is
somehow bigotry that this somehow
manifests animus they're not going to do
that and if the Democrats if the left in
this country decide that they're going
to shut down religion in the country if
they decide they're going to shut down
any moral principle that differs from
theirs on very personal moral issues
including issues regarding how they
raise their children with regard to
gender and sex then this country is
simply not going to last because if you
have states like California that decide
to go full social leftist and
effectively make illegal any viewpoint
that is not the social Left line
everybody who is not that is gonna have
to move out of the state and you're
gonna see a vast separation in the
country and if you want to Americans
this is how you're gonna get it not
through economics not through Medicare
for all those are open debates that can
be had but if you are fundamentally
questioning the principles of a fellow
American to the point where you are
effectively threatening to indoctrinate
their children with your principles
because you think that your principles
are so sacrosanct and their principles
are so evil well that is the basis for
actual conflicts in the country I don't
think it'll come to armed conflict in
this country I think instead what you
will have is a vast population
separation and then a mutual parting of
ways if this continues the reason I say
this is because I actually spent some
time watching that Democratic Town Hall
last night the so called the quality
Town Hall the LGBTQ Town Hall and it was
not about equality it was about
discrimination against religious people
it was about rage against people who
disagree with the prevailing social Left
agenda it is that simple that is what
that was and it was not about we just
want tolerance we just want acceptance
first of all tolerance and acceptance
are not the same thing they are not I
tolerate lots of behavior that I don't
accept
I tolerate lots of behavior that I
believe to be wrong right that is what
it means to be American is to tolerate
viewpoints and behavior that you may not
think is wrong but that does not
actually change your life or hurt you in
any way
okay toleration and acceptance not
exactly the same thing but the Democrats
want to go one further and that is
celebration Eric Erickson my colleague
has said before you will be made to care
and it's not just you will be made to
care it's not just enough for you to
throw up your hands and say listen do
what you want float your whatever floats
your boat that's not enough what the
left wants is your approval it's not
just acceptance its approval they want
your celebration it
you are not properly celebrating this is
evidence that you are a bad bad person
who's be knighted and indoctrinated by
centuries of religious bigotry and all
of this and the Democrats went full bore
on that last night they were cutting
campaign commercials for Donald Trump
last night if you want Americans to go
out and vote for Donald Trump do this
because I'll be honest with you over the
last week Trump's had a terrible week
Trump's had an awful week between all
the impeachment gay talk and Ukraine and
president Trump pulling it out of the
the Kurdish areas of northern Syria and
getting blowback from his own party for
that it's made him an extremely
unattractive candidate for a lot of
people in the middle and even a few
people on the right but if you want
people like me to walk over broken glass
on my knees to vote for Trump all you
have to do is tell me you're gonna
outlaw my synagogue that's all you have
to do all you have to do is tell me that
you're gonna tell me I can't raise my
kid the way I feel I should raise my kid
because let me tell you something you
don't know my kid's name you don't know
a damn thing about my kid
and I will raise my kid better than you
will and yes I'm talking to you
Elizabeth Warren and Cory Booker and Amy
clapper chart if you think you can
educate my kid better than I can educate
my kid you can go after yourself and I
know there are millions tens of millions
probably hundreds of millions of
Americans who feel the same way and what
we saw last night on CNN was an abject
attempt to seize the reigns of cultural
conversation not just to push not just
to convince but to cram down if you are
talking about using the heavy hand of
government to cram down your social
viewpoint you are no different from the
people who you label theocrats on the
other side you say that there are people
who are theocratic on the other side
these evil horrible religious people who
want to use religious principle and ram
that down on you from above right this
is what the left is constantly claiming
and I keep saying I don't see the
theocracy where is it
you keep saying Mike Pence is a
theocratic please name the things that
are theocratic that Mike Pence has done
but your religion of social leftism it
is indeed a religion and you are the
ones who are seeking to take control of
a government and then use it to destroy
how I raised my child the people with
whom I associate how I practice my
religion I've not done anything to you
I've not done anything to you I was
libertarian on same-sex marriage before
or Bursch fell okay the fact is that you
are still trying to come in and wreck my
community you're trying to wreck if I
raise my child you're you're basically
at the verge of threatening my ability
to raise my own child
it's insane I'm going to show you clips
from this Democratic
Town Hall in just one second and you
will see the Animus for religion you
will see the desire to use the federal
government as a club to beat into
submission anyone who disagrees on
social policy you want a country to last
you have to live and let live it was
funny I thought that was the I thought
that was basically the slogan of the gay
rights movement right was live and let
live we're not bothering you leave us
alone fine good okay well I'm not
bothering you
leave me alone and if you don't leave me
alone well then I'm gonna have to fight
back I'm either gonna have to move or
I'm gonna have to fight back those are
the only two choices you are leaving
available to people when you will not
let them live and let live and when you
dictate that their entire way of raising
their children is morally wrong and been
knighted and that your and more than
that not just morally condemning those
people which is fine right it's a free
country you can morally condemn whoever
you see fit I by the way the left should
know this right they're busy morally
condemning everybody who disagrees with
them that there are 93 separate genders
that attack helicopter is gender they're
busy telling everyone who's like that
they're ignorant and terrible but they
have no such sympathy for people on the
right who say you know what I disagree
and I think that there are only two
genders male and female and that my
child is born the biology that they are
born or that I believe according to
natural law principles that heterosexual
behavior is morally superior to
homosexual behavior not because of
religious principle because of natural
law principles that men and women belong
together
that they produce families that produce
children and that is not in any way a
justification of discrimination against
people who are homosexual that is not in
any way a justification of nastiness
against people who are gay that is not
in any way a justification of people
discriminating against people who behave
in in certain ways but that is a moral
judgment I get to make that moral
judgment in my own life and help them
with regard to how I raise my kids and
live my life just as you get to make a
moral judgment about me it's a free
country
feel free whatever floats your boat
morally but I'm willing to say that some
people aren't a lot of people on the
left and the Democratic Party are simply
not willing to say that they're not
willing to acknowledge that in any way
shape or form and that is what we are
about to see it's not just about social
disapproval of people who disagree is
about using the power of government to
target people who disagree and this is
where you raise everybody's hackles it's
not just about you saying that I'm
morally wrong because I disapprove of
homosexuality honor
on religious and natural law level and
you can say that fine first of all I
don't even care I don't even know why
you care what I think about these things
as I say I'm libertarian whatever floats
your boat but it's not about that for
the Democrats for the Democrats it's
about how we enshrine our principles in
law and force you force you to behave in
ways that conflict with both your
religious and moral principles and you
want to break apart the country this is
the way to do it we'll get some more of
this in a second I'm going to jump into
this Democratic Town Hall because it was
truly insulting on virtually every level
I mean when when Barack Obama suggested
that religious Americans are bitter
clinger is clinging to God and guns and
religion when when people talk about the
scorn that the high-level left has four
traditional Americans and for basically
everyone living somewhere between in Los
Angeles in New York this is what they
are talking about we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
hiring hiring can actually be slow and
difficult if you want to get the right
people you have to make sure you have
the right people the last thing you want
is to hire somebody and then you have to
somehow cudgel them into being a good
employee hiring is all about finding the
right person and then setting them free
to fulfill their potential now you know
who can help you do that the folks over
at zip recruiter com zip recruiter will
help you find employers employees within
the very first day four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the very
first day so let's say that you have an
employee who you know really tries his
best but simply can't get clips done on
time you're like Holton or something and
and you wanted to replace : well what
you would do is go over to zip recruiter
comms if recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes tries to procure
for free and our web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that is
zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly Wira zip
recruiter comm slash at daily wires zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire go check them out right now at zip
record comm slash daily wire see the
thing about that ad is the dipper
whoever's in the room gets the short
straw so for the next several weeks
Colton is gonna get smacked with the
zipper
these Colton's traveling me with with me
while we are out of town okay so he
actually did a good job pulling clips
this morning I will say good for you
cool okay so in any case this Democratic
Town Hall was a full-scale display of
insanity let's start with the most the
most ardent of the Democrats so it used
to be the Bernie Sanders was the voice
of the most crazy Democrats now it's
maydel is desperate for attention and
because he's desperate for attention and
he's just standing outside every
Democratic forum sort of like the the
weird balloon guy that you see on the
top of car dealerships are just kind of
waving his arms all wild like crazy guy
that that's beta O'Rourke now my beta
old rock will say anything for attention
but he does represent the at root most
radical and most true Democratic
positions
so yesterday beta O'Rourke said the
thing out loud last night he said the
thing out loud that Democrats have
refused to say I've been saying that
this is what they want for years I've
been saying for years that the real
danger of the social left movement in
the United States is that they were
going to go up against every Church
religious institution religious school
in America their goal was going to be to
use same-sex marriage not to preserve
the ability of two men to have tax
benefits for being married or to women's
have tax benefits for being married or
anything like that that was not the
actual end goal that was not gonna be
the end of the road the end of the road
was going to be using laws that make
such marriages enshrined sacrosanct by
law using those to club it into
submission and destroy religious
institutions the next step would be to
do the Bob Jones University move the Bob
Jones University move back in the early
1980s there was a federal tax case in
which the IRS decided to remove
tax-exempt status from Bob Jones
University why well because Bob Jones
University had an anti interracial
dating policy the policy was benign
stupid and ignorant and immoral okay Bob
Jones had that policy there was nothing
in IRS policy that suggested that you
could simply remove tax-exempt status
from organizations that had such rules
but the folks at the IRS decided you
know what we don't like what Bob Jones
University is doing it's discriminatory
tax exempt status removed so the Supreme
Court ruled that they could do that they
could remove tax-exempt status well by
basically equating same-sex marriage
which is not the same as interracial
marriage buttock weighting the - by
saying that race is the same as sex when
it comes to marriage which is a patently
insane position because male and female
are inherently different in a very very
different way then people who have
different skin colors right different
skin colors is a thing that does not
matter when it comes to the ability to
function as a married couple okay when
it comes to two males and two females
versus a male and a female one of the
key functions of marriage historically
speaking has been the production and
rearing of children when I say one of
the key
I mean really a ducky function right so
that makes a bit of a difference but by
ik waiting same-sex marriage with
interracial marriage I said the next
move of the left was going to be to
declare that every major religious
institution in the United States was
basically operating in discriminatory
fashion remove their tax-exempt status
once you remove their tax-exempt status
and you said they don't have tax-exempt
status any more you treat them like a
normal LLC well if you know the
anti-discrimination laws in states like
California or through the Democratic
Party and you're trying to pass the
so-called Equality Act which is really a
way of cracking down on religious
institutions and forcing people to abide
by social rules that they don't want to
abide by and in violation of the First
Amendment blatant violation of the First
Amendment the founders were are spinning
so fast in their grades they're drilling
directly to the core of the earth at
this point okay the fact is that the the
goal here would be to then kick these
religious institutions from 501c3
tax-exempt since institutions into
normal LLC territory and then declare
that those LLC's are in violation of
non-discrimination policies and shut
them down as violative of law we've
already seen them do this with Arlene's
flowers in Washington State where if you
are a a florist who is religious and
only will cater to weddings that are
traditional you will be shut down or
fine
we see with photographers we've seen it
with with with Jack Phillips the Baker
in Colorado right we've seen all of that
again we've seen the Democrats and the
left to do this they're gonna do that to
your church they're gonna remove
tax-exempt status and they're gonna shut
it down I'm gonna do it to your
religious school in fact they're more
likely to go after the religious school
they'll just say no more accreditation
if you don't teach what we want on LGBT
topics we're just gonna shut you down
because you're not teaching your
children properly and if you say listen
I'm gonna find do that I'm gonna now
have homeschool right me and my friends
are gonna get together our homeschool
they will come in and they will shut
that down as a as a fake school they
won't come after your children for
truancy those will be the next steps and
people say oh that's alarmism we would
never do that we would never do that we
would never come after you
I mean come on live and let live right
you're not bothering anyone live and let
live yeah bethe Ulrich just destroyed
any semblance of of that notion last
night during this CNN Town Hall it was
crazy but this is this is the actual
position of the Democratic Party well
get to that in one second first let's
talk about the fact that you're losing
your hair
two out of three Jews will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they are 35 I am
unlucky my mom's family her dad he
balded really early so I've been deeply
worried about losing my hair but with it
but there is good news with today's
advancements in science heaps offers
proven treatments that can combat the
symptoms of hair loss keeps his
revolutionised way men are treated for
hair loss used to have to go to the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription now thanks to keeps you can
visit a doctor online and get
medications delivered to your home no
more waiting rooms no more pharmacy
checkout lines get doctor attention and
discreet drug delivery all from the
comfort and privacy of your own home
prevention is the key once the hair is
gone and very hard to regrow keeps
treatments really do work they're up to
90 percent effective at reducing and
stopping further hair loss the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair you
are going to save so go check them out
right now their treatment starts with
just 10 bucks a month plus for a limited
time you can get your first month for
free they make it super easy to keep the
hair you have if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to keeps
calm slash Ben's receive your first
month of treatment for free that is ke
EPS calm slash Ben keeps calm slash
Ben's receive that first month of
treatment for free okay so as I say the
Democrats decided they're going to cut a
bunch of ads for Donald Trump last night
beta a work led the way here is bado
explaining that colleges and churches
that oppose same-sex marriage should
lose their tax-exempt status so he is
saying exactly what I have been saying
for 10 years people have been saying
that I was alarmist about all of this
one of the reasons I'm a libertarian on
same-sex marriages not just because I
don't think that the government has a
role in regulating activity that doesn't
harm anybody else but also because I was
deeply afraid that the government
getting it involved and redefining
marriage to include same-sex marriage
would end in exactly with what Bane
O'Rourke is talking about right here
so here is beta or are saying straight
out that he wants to remove tax-exempt
status which is the first step toward
basically getting rid of these
institutions altogether from every
college every church that opposes the
same-sex marriage right any institution
that he says any charity what does he
think churches our churches our
charities remove tax-exempt status they
won't be tax exempt any longer so you
won't be able to give charity to your
church because if you do you'll be
acting in discriminatory ways here's
baitul work saying it out loud colleges
churches charities should they lose
their tax-exempt status if they oppose
same-sex marriage yes there can be no
no benefit no tax break for anyone or
inst any institution any organization in
America that denies the full human
rights and a full civil rights of every
single one of us and so as president
we're going to make that a priority and
we are going to stop those who are
infringing upon the human rights of our
fellow Americans okay so in other words
if you're a church you're not infringing
on anybody's rights
you're just saying you can't come here
for your marriage go to the church down
the street you're a religious school
you're saying listen you want to learn
about gay rights go to the public school
down the street okay you want to learn
about gay rights you can just go to that
secular atheistic crossroads school in
Santa Monica like enjoy yourself that's
your problem go enjoy fine
you're not infringing on anybody your
mere existence is an infringement
according to bethe or or the
institutional existence is an
infringement on Liberty according to
bethe O'Rourke and you must be shut down
you want a culture war in this country
you damned what we'll have a beta
O'Rourke you want a culture one this
country with this country to come apart
at the seams this is how you do it
because I promise you if you come to
tell me that you're going to
indoctrinate my kids in particular
policy and then I can't pull my kid out
of the school and send my kids to a
school I want to send them to then I
can't go to the church or synagogue that
I want to go to and if you make that
national policy not just California
policy where I can move but national
policy people are not gonna stand for
that they're not going to stand for that
and if you send a truant officer to
remove my child I have two choices at
that point right if I have no place to
move because you've now made this
national federal policy I know have two
choices one is to leave the country
utterly two is to pick up a gun those
are the only choices that you have left
me and now people on the way all this is
how could you say something like that
how could you be so extreme it's not
extreme to defend the fundamental rights
the Constitution was created in order to
protect these rights pre-exists
government my right to raise my child in
my faith is my right that is a First
Amendment right there's only one reason
the government exists to protect those
rights not invade those rights it is my
rights raised my child with the moral
precepts that I find to be beneficial
for my child they don't work does not
get to raise my child and if he tries I
will meet him at the door with a gun
that is insane that is insane if he
tries to remove my child from and people
well he's not suggesting it where do you
think this goes what do you think the
next step is if
I mean he's saying it openly there can
be no reward for doing this
how far is reward from compulsion how
far does reward from come up because the
Equality Act basically suggests that
businesses should be shut down if they
disagree with bata O'Rourke okay I'm
looking three steps down the road this
is where this is going and the fact that
there are people on the Left weren't
sheering for this do they want this
conflict you want to live in a country
with me I want to live in a country with
you I just agree what they don't work on
all this stuff he's still an American I
still want to live in a country with him
he obviously doesn't want to live in a
country with me or anyone like me he
wants us changed to meet his his
definition of the good his definition of
the higher moral decency the answer
there is no and it wasn't her spayed or
rook last night as we'll see was a bunch
of candidates a bunch of candidates and
if they weren't saying it out loud that
was the basic theme the basic theme was
we are gonna cram down on all of
American society our views on this is
this is theocracy it is theocracy of the
left it is religious rule of the left
because there is no data to back this up
okay this is not a data-driven social
science driven teaching this is not
driven by evidence this is driven by a
religious conviction that the leveling
of all human beings and the attempt to
level all human behavior to the same
moral level is an inherent good that is
a religious faith-based belief there's
no evidence of it what's more I'll show
you the lack of evidence for what these
folks are saying in just one second
because it's patently crazy I'll get to
that in a moment first let's talk about
the Second Amendment so as you may
notice I've mentioned a couple of times
in the context of defending rights
already the importance of the Second
Amendment hey the fact is that if you're
a law-abiding American you should have a
gun for several reasons including the
protection of yourself from actual armed
invasion the protection from threat the
protection from people who want to come
and hurt you well when the founders
crafted the Constitution when they
crafted the First Amendment they wanted
to protect our rights and then they
crafted the Second Amendment to allow us
to protect our rights that's why I am a
gun owner owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility building rifles is no
different started in a garage by a
Marine veteran more than two decades ago
Bravo company manufacturing BCM for
short builds a professional-grade
product which is built to combat
standards Bravo Company manufacturing is
not a sporting arms company they design
engineer and manufacture life-saving
equipment the people at BCM assume that
when a rifle leaves their shop it will
be you
in a life-or-death situation by a
responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas to learn
more about Bravo company manufacturing
head on over to Bravo Company MFG comm
and you can discover more about their
products special offers and upcoming
news that's Bravo Company MFG comm if
you need more convincing find out even
more about BCM and the awesome people
who make their products at youtube.com
slash bravo company USA that is Bravo
Company MFG comm go check them out right
now they make awesome products ok so
it's not just a beta O'Rourke who has
been doing this extremist routine it's
also cory booker here's cory booker
yesterday suggesting the catholic
schools across the country is basically
suggesting we should shut down every
Catholic school in America cory booker
he says Catholic schools across the
country are using religion to justify
discrimination insane and so for me I
cannot allow as a leader that people are
going to use a religion as a
justification for discrimination you
could respect your religious freedoms
but also protect people from
discrimination and as I said in an
earlier answer I grew up in a household
where my parents talk to me about how
people used to use religion to justify
the discrimination against African
Americans I cannot allow who the F are
you dude you cannot allow guess what
that's not your right my right is to act
in ways that don't harm anybody else and
if I choose to have an institution where
I am going to elevate heterosexuality
above homosexuality that is not harming
anyone else you don't have to
participate in that institution it's a
free country I mean you have
institutions where you don't tolerate my
religious beliefs I don't expect it when
I walk into a mosque that suddenly
they're gonna start practicing Judaism I
don't expect it when I walk into an
atheist meeting they're gonna start
keeping kosher and I don't expect that
when I walk into the offices of the
Human Rights Campaign that they're going
to start handing out literature from
Leviticus like why in the world would
you not expressed the same degree of
tolerance for people who disagree with
you toward then toward people you agree
with if you want only tolerance and
people who agree with you this is a good
is a good indicator you're not a very
tolerant person you will not allow first
of all the very implication that the
reason the Catholics are against
homosexual activity is simply out of
bigotry and discrimination is a
in absolute ignorance of Catholicism
it's an absolute ignorance of the
natural law history of Catholicism of
the natural law arguments with regard to
human sexuality for the same reason the
Catholics are against abortion and
contraception they're also against
homosexual activity namely they believe
that the end of contrast at the end of
the sexual act is procreation and that
because sex is directed toward
procreation and toward the deepening of
relationship relationships that end with
procreation heterosexual sex ought to be
favored over homosexuals activity or by
the way over activity that ends with
pregnancy outside of marriage over
adultery over polygamy I mean there are
plenty of sexual rules in religion and
picking out one of them and pretending
that that's the only one that matters is
pretty insane by the left anyway it
demonstrates a full-scale lack of
understanding of how our religion works
but notice that for the left they truly
believe many people on the left like
Booker they truly believe that practice
of religion is in and of itself
discrimination okay well guess what
religion is exclusive hey my synagogue
is about practicing 613 commandments and
if you don't practice a commandment that
be a sin Catholic faith one of the
tenants of Catholic faith is that you
have to believe in Jesus if you don't
believe in Jesus you're doing something
wrong now you have to have a faith in
Christ and if you don't then you are
excluded from the Catholic faith right
you are not a practitioner of the
Catholic faith is that discriminatory
sure but that's called religion okay and
guess what
Cory Booker's discriminatory - because I
am barred from the Kingdom of Heaven
because he and I disagree on social
leftism amazing tolerance only flows one
way it only flows one way it flows from
people like me religious people like me
remember any problem with Cory Booker
feeling what he wants to believe or
human rights campaign believe in what
they want to believe or GLAAD believing
what they want to believe
do what you want man it's a free country
but that's how Lawrence does not extend
back the other way not in any way shape
or form and he can't have a society that
operates this way by the way Cory Booker
is crazy okay Cory Booker was he asked
about the pulse terror attack for those
who don't remember the post terror
attack it was up until the attack in Las
Vegas I believe the deadliest terror
attack in the United States since and we
still in Los Vegas was effectually a
terrorist attack or a mass shooting it's
kind of on that fuzzy border of
classification because there's no actual
political motive there we know the
motivation impulse we're forty nine
people were killed at this gay bar
motivation at pulse was Islamic radical
terrorism Cory Booker tries to blame it
on white supremacy because we can never
mention the intersectional conflict
between radical Islam been gay rights
whenever Cory Booker or beta Iraq are
attacking someplace notice how they
always attack synagogues and churches
you never have anything to say about
mosques that believe exactly the same
thing as synagogues and churches on
traditional sexual morality
here's Cory Booker being a and
suggesting that white supremacy was
responsible for the pulse terror attack
so first of all very clearly it is a
national emergency the majority of
terrorist attacks in this country since
9/11 have been right-wing extremist
groups the majority of them have been
white supremacists in hate groups and
and I will elevate as president United
States and office on hate crimes and
white supremacy to make sure it is a
presidential-level
effort to content to protect our country
as a whole but I'm not stopping there
okay by the way the question here a
question that put that Booker was asked
was about the pulse terror attack it
sounds like he's being asked about tree
of life or something who's asked about
the post terror attack which was
committed by natural terrorists okay by
a National Islamic terrorist tree of
life was committed by white supremacists
Harris a bit of a difference there in
just one second we are going to get to
more from this insane townhall because
some of this was attitude no and you've
noticed that I'm putting the attitudinal
stuff below the compulsive stuff the
compulsory stuff because I don't think
it's quite as important it's still
important because the attitudinal the
attitudinal direction toward these
issues is informing the beta overall
Cory Booker we're going to cram down our
viewpoints on you routine and the
viewpoint itself is wildly out of step
with evidence so as I say this is not
about we're bringing the best social
science data to bear in a completely
secular way and if that affects religion
it affects religion as Justice Scalia
would have said about religious practice
it is a neutral law of neutral
applicability right that it's it's just
a law that that applies to everybody and
it is not specifically directed at
religion no this is not a neutral law
okay this is non evidence-based
viewpoints on human relations that is
gonna be crammed down in religious
fashion we're gonna get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
earbuds that you're using to listen to
this show right now maybe you got the
old fashioned earbuds with the big wires
that go down to your phone maybe you
have the really expensive earbuds and
you're afraid you're gonna lose one
remember you didn't lose one of them
now you need a replacement well ray Kahn
is the place to go Rick honey Air Bud
started about half the price of any
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market they sound just as amazing as
other top audio brands that you know but
the latest model is the best one yet six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass a more compact design
because you a nice noise isolating fit
ray cons wireless earbuds are so
comfortable they are perfect for
on-the-go listening and for taking phone
calls and unlike some of the other
wireless options they don't have any
sort of wires or stems they are stylish
and discreet I really love my retcons
they come in a variety of colors and
actually a bunch of different fits in
case you have a different shaped ear now
is the time to get the latest and
greatest from Ray con get 15% off your
order at buy break on Comm slash Ben
that is Bui are a YCL n comm / pen for
15% off rake on wireless earbuds that is
buy rake on comm / pen once more
Bui RA Y Co mancom / Ben go check them
out right now by ray con-com / Ben okay
in just a second we're gonna get to the
rest of this Democratic Town Hall and
then we will get to I mean it was it was
insane man it was wild and then we'll
get to the rudy giuliani of it all and
the whistleblower of impeachment good
tour you are G will get to that update
in just a second first folks the daily
wires long-awaited app is finally here
it's fantastic if you're a subscriber
you can access all of our contents
including articles shows and more
straight from the app all-access
subscribers get our new and exclusive
discussion features where they can
interact directly with our hosts writers
and other special guests the app is
available on Apple and Android so
download it today become a subscriber
and come and join the fun also you
should subscribe because you get access
to our Sunday special this Sunday is
Neil deGrasse Tyson we just has a
variety of science-based issues from
global warming to transgenderism it gets
kind of spicy go check it out this
Saturday if you happen to be a
subscriber but you have to wait till
Sunday if you're not also if you
subscribe as you know 9 to 10 bucks a
year you get the great it's an all
beverage vessels the leftist Cheers hot
or cold who cast your eyes upon it and
weep that you have it not but you could
if you go over to Daley wire comet right
now 99 bucks a year gets you that and
all the other goodies
we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so the attitude of the
Democrats here is just as insane as
their contention that the government
ought to be used to cram down that
attitude Amy Klobuchar who's the
supposed moderate senator from Minnesota
she committed in the middle of the
townhall to putting a third gender on
federal identification so you can
arbitrarily decide that you are this
third gender now notice this is not
evidence-based there's no test that we
can use to determine whether you are
this their gender now they're pretty
obvious tests we can use to determine
whether you're a male or a female namely
we can look at your birth certificate as
a first as a first line of resort and if
you're intersex well that is a very
small percentage of the population but
that's an objective test to because we
can either use genetic testing or in
some cases if you happen to have genetic
anomalies then we can actually check you
there needs to be some objective metric
in other words when you're looking at
government data what you would like is
objectivity
you don't want subjectivity for example
we would laugh if Rachel Dolezal said on
her ID that she's a black person but we
want to reclassify her as a not black
person as a white person why because
she's a white lady okay and that's how
do we know by looking at her and looking
at her parents right really not
difficult as it turns out sex is even
less difficult because race is to a
certain extent of fuzzy construct right
there is sort of fuzzy lines around race
because how black is black how white is
white we don't actually know but we damn
well know how female is female namely
you got two X chromosomes right you have
the sry gene and that's what this will
help determine whether you are male or
female right this is this is really not
tough but any club achar wants in
completely evidence less fashion to
allow you to randomly recap week
recategorize yourself as male female or
other on your federal ID I mean are
these people cutting campaign
commercials for Trump or what's the deal
here I currently identify as non-binary
in California I am able to change my
gender to X however on the federal level
there is no such option will you
recognize their gender markers on a
federal level yes yes oh yeah of course
of course I identify as non-binary I
identify as not identify is an immediate
giveaway that the government should not
actually be recognizing your position
your self-identification is of zero
relevance when it comes to checking your
gender when you get pulled over at a
traffic stop okay your ID is used to
identify you that notice ID has to do
with identification how others identify
you that's what an ID is for your ID is
not a five paragraph essay on how you
feel about the movie Titanic your ID is
about objective identification by others
of you when I travel with a passport you
know what they do they look at my
picture on the passport then they look
at me then they look at the picture then
they look at me and they go oh that's
you you know I can tell it's you can I
have this objective identification right
here this ID and it tells me exactly who
you are what if instead of that it
didn't have I said you know I don't
identify as my picture I don't that's
not how I feel on the inside I feel like
a woman and so my picture does not
really identify Who I am on the inside
like this is it defeats the purpose of
an idea what the hell are you talking
about what are you ten evidence now
everybody cheers cuz it's very tolerant
oh it's so tolerant but guess what the
government policy is not about tolerance
when it comes to ID there are certain
there other areas where it is when it
comes to racial non-discrimination for
example but when it comes to trying to
identify you to get on a plane it seems
like it should matter to the TSA whether
they can identify you as the correct
gender or not these they're pretty clear
obvious physical markers of this sort of
thing like this woman okay this is
pretty obviously a woman identifies as
quote-unquote non-binary okay well but I
just told you this is a woman because
how can by using my eyes I know it was
it was very very difficult and then you
had the pandering of Kamala Harris who
announced her pronouns this is the new
routine on the left to demonstrate that
you believe the gender doesn't exist and
the gender is an arbitrary constructs
and that you can pick your own gender
you know have to you don't have to
identify the own pronouns by which you
wish to be called because the world must
be shaped according to your whim when
you talk about tolerance by the way
tolerance is expressly about your
ability to recognize that other people
view the world in a way different from
you that's what tolerance is tolerance
is about I recognize that you view the
world in a way that is different from me
but the entire basis of the pronouns
abate is in the rest of the world must
never view the world in a different way
based on objectively defined
characteristics the rest of the world
must define the world how I wish to
define the world
because I have no objective standard my
standard changes day to day I can change
my gender however I please but you have
to identify me by what I wish to be
identified as that is the least tolerant
position of all time the least tolerant
position is I identify the world in a
certain way based on no objective
markers that you can see or that I can
see but you're supposed to redefine your
entire reality and the rest of the world
is to around whatever pronouns I choose
so here is Kamala Harris announcing her
pronouns and then Chris Cuomo being an
idiot and trying to identify as a woman
as well
[Applause]
thank you and my pronouns are she her
and hers she her mine too all right
I mean is Chris Cuomo just like a
complete full-scale idiot and here's
made a mistake there or is he actually
making a joke about the pronouns stuff
because if he's making a joke about the
pronoun something's kind of funny if in
fact he is identifying as a woman well
then that sort of undercuts the entire
basis of the argument does it not
because we all know Chris Cuomo is not a
woman Chris Cuomo is not Fredo I mean we
all know how to identify Chris Cuomo at
this point the over-the-top nature of
this of this event is so crazy I mean so
crazy for example like Joe Biden is just
the most awkward human being alive and
there are a couple of moments that prove
this so in the middle of this debate Joe
Biden just launches into this thing
about the wonders of same-sex marriage
fine you know make that case that's
totally cool you want to make the case
that same-sex marriage is better than
none then non marriage and that monogamy
is better than non not great go for it
but he starts launching into this this
soliloquy about how gay couples are
better than straight couples gay couples
are more likely to stay together than
straight couples now by data this is not
true
there's exactly one study of which I am
aware out of Vermont and it sort of it's
like 500 couples and what it found is
that female same-sex couples are
significantly more likely to break up
than heterosexual couples and that male
couples are more likely to stay together
that is a small sample size and it's in
Vermont there's a broader study that
happened in Bowling Green State
University in 2017 they sampled 14,000
individuals including three distinct
types of couples different sexes female
same-sex couples and male same-sex
couples and heterosexual couples were
far more likely to stay together
than either of the other two types of
couples what's more when Joe Biden says
this sort of stuff and he talked about
couples staying together he's failing to
also define the nature of the
relationship what I mean by that is that
if you were going to define staying
together as like living in the same
house then I guess that's one way to
define it if you were going to define it
as monogamy then same-sex couples are
not operating in the same universe as
heterosexual couples in terms of
monogamy and that's not according to me
that's according to the gay couple study
out of San Francisco State University
which followed 500 gay couples over many
years and found that about half the
couples have sex with someone other than
their part
with their partner knowing so open
marriage is actually more the at least
the rule than the exception at the very
least it's a very large minority of
same-sex couples that are engaged in
extra marital sexual behavior with the
consent of the other partner that's a
very different type of relationship than
monogamous heterosexual relationships
which are generally expected to be
monogamous and by the way that is a
statistically driven argument about the
nature of these relationships that Joe
Biden is ignoring in order to pander so
here is Joe Biden pandering Jay couples
are more likely to stay together longer
than heterosexual couples okay again not
statistically true except for one study
from Vermont which tends to be an
outlier that wasn't even nearly the
weirdest moment for Joe Biden he went
over to Anderson Cooper nearly kissed
him I mean this was the Michael Scott
and Oscar scene from the office where
Michael is trying to demonstrate how
Lawrence he is of same sex couples cuz
Oscar comes out of the closet and so
Michael goes over and tries to kiss him
on the lips
this nearly happened on national TV with
Joe Biden how they think this guy's a
frontrunner is beyond me and I gotta
tell you you know he's a great guy I'm
and I went in on Monday and all the
national press saying Biden's gonna
really get nailed when he walks into
sees the president morning he got up and
he walked over to me said well you told
me he gave me a kiss I swear to God so
just kind of basic stuff no love and
Anderson in the crowd laughs awkwardly
Anderson Cooper leans away like oh my
god
worst moment for Anderson Cooper since
Donald sterling asked him if he had ever
been in love with a woman so that was
the that is one of the great moments in
TV history Anderson is like no good
stuff there from Joe Biden the the
cruelest moment I thought was a moment
from the CNN producers okay and this is
cruel because you should not exploit
children on national TV no matter what
the children are doing no matter who the
children are you should not exploit
children okay so there was this moment
during the debate and there's a nine
year old transgender kid okay which is a
girl who believes that she is a boy this
is a child who is suffering from gender
dysphoria okay that is a that I cannot
imagine what it would be like to suffer
from gender dysphoria
I seriously have nothing but sympathy
for people who sell
for from gender identity disorder or
gender dysphoria it must be just the
most painful thing and when people write
about it they say it is the most painful
thing if a nine year olds who is
suffering from this a nine year old
right who's not hit puberty yet and so
it doesn't know the full meaning of what
it means to be a member of the
quote/unquote opposite gender because
without the full development of brain
the full development of testosterone or
estrogen how could you possibly know
what it's like in prepubescent fashion
to be a member of the opposite sex
things changed pretty radically when you
become a hormonal and anyways in any
case this nine-year-old transgender boy
is brought out by by her parents because
this is a girl brought out by her
parents and she asks the question to
Elizabeth Warren and the purpose of this
for CNN is to make it impossible to
question Elizabeth Warren's answer and
also to basically emotionally blackmail
the audience into suggesting that if you
believe it's exploitative for CNN to do
this if you believe it's exploitative of
this kid's parents it and I do I believe
it's deeply exploitative of this kid's
parents I feel awful for this child it's
it's just it's a terrible terrible thing
to question it to turn a child into a
political tool is a deeply wrong thing
and this is true whether you are taking
your kid and forcing your kid to protest
at rallies on police brutality or
abortion or whether you are choosing to
take your kid and trot them out on
national television to talk about their
own mental state and nine years old I
don't care what your mental state is
talk about your mental state on public
television at nine years old is insane
it's insane for the from CNN to do this
to this kid I feel awful for this kid
and they bring out this kid to question
Elizabeth Warren and this is treated as
a great heroic moment for Elizabeth
Warren children should not be treated
like this in any context let alone a
context where the kid is suffering from
a condition and whatever you believe
about transgenderism and the ability or
manly ability of gender there's no
question that gender identity disorder
is a condition and the gender dysphoria
is a condition a painful condition at
that here is this moment this very
terrible moment that CNN voiced again
not for the kid not this has nothing to
do with with the child this has to do
with the exploitation of the child for
whom I feel awful really truly I have
children I have a child who's five I'm a
child who's three I cannot imagine doing
this to my kid and I can't imagine
allowing a national television network
to do this to my child anyway here is
here is the CNN doing this
my name is Jacob and Ireland
nine-year-old transgender American my
question is what were you doing your
first week as president to make sure
that kids like me feel safer in schools
and what do you think schools need to do
better to make sure that I don't have to
worry about anything but my homework
there's no purpose to having the kid ask
that question the mom can ask that
question the mom is right there she has
a microphone next to her the only
purpose in having the kid ask the
question is to create this situation
where if you say anything that is
politically incorrect about the nature
of for example locker rooms in schools
that girls should have their own locker
rooms and boys should have their own
locker rooms and that girls should not
be allowed to go into boys locker rooms
and vice versa if you say any of that
stuff you are now considered intolerant
and bigoted that's the whole purpose of
doing that it's the whole purpose and
the end the evidence free cheering of a
declaration that a child can determine
their own gender at 9:00 show me the
evidence that this is the case show me
the evidence that this is that that this
is objectively speaking the case that
this child has been it is actually a boy
and not a biological girl this is a
child suffering from a condition the
exploitation of that condition I mean I
want these people raising my child you
think I want you you think I want
elizabeth warren deciding how I raised
my child you think I want the Democrats
and Chris Cuomo and CNN deciding how I
raise my child a good good luck with
that good luck with that
okay well unfortunately we weren't able
to get to any of the other news because
this filled up the entire episode of
this show we will bring you all the
latest news next week when we are not in
the middle of Jewish holiday again
there's another Jewish holiday that is
Monday Tuesday in the United States so
get to all of the latest on impeachment
agree 2019 and all of that
next week suffice it to say that in the
great social battle which is the most
divisive battle because you're talking
about how we raise our kids where we go
to church how we deal with our neighbors
if you believe the government should
cram down left point of view you are
dividing the country in a way that is
nearly making it nearly a
concil and that is what the left is
seeking to do on a daily basis and they
even exploit children who are suffering
with a condition in order to do that
they will exploit children to do that
you think I'm gonna trust these folks on
how to raise my kid handle my church
deal with charity in my community not a
damn chance okay time for a quick thing
I like so things that I like to directly
the thing I hate because frankly the the
prospect of a Democratic Party that
wants to shut down all religious
practice across the nation and dictate
how you raise your kids is frightening
enough for today's episode but a thing I
like so as I've mentioned I am in Israel
for the all the Jewish holidays and it's
pretty amazing it's pretty Esther day I
had the opportunity to visit a place
called the city of David now when people
think of the City of David they think of
the Tower of David and all the lead this
is the Tower of David which is in old
Jerusalem does not actually have
anything to a David it was built by the
Crusaders so it was way after the time
of David the City of David is the actual
archeological dig site that is just to
the south east I believe of Jerusalem in
the in the valley and that's where the
actual original city of Jerusalem used
to be the Old City of Jerusalem has only
really been built up over the past five
hundred years the original city of
Jerusalem like where David used to live
and where his and where his dynasty rule
is actually away it's like it's kind of
to the south of the of the Temple Mount
and they've been uncovering all sorts of
antiquities over there one of the big
battles right now in politics is the
Muslim worlds large lots and Muslim
worlds their denial of the Jewish
history of Israel the Jewish history of
Jerusalem which is patently insane they
deny the Christian history the
Palestinian Authority for example deny
the Christian history of Israel as well
because that's based on the Jewish
history so they can't allow that either
well you go and visit the City of David
you can actually see what they now
believe was the palace of the Davidic
dynasty and not only that they have now
obviously uncovered the 24 hundred year
old staircase that went from the the
large scale pool where people would
cleanse themselves in ceremonial fashion
all the way up and what they called
Aliaga região they would actually ascend
to the Temple Mount for the temple
worship service yeah this is this road
it's it's now underground they've been
uncovering it at exorbitant cost they've
been uncovering this this vast stone
staircase that
travels upward probably half a mile and
this is the place Jesus walks I mean the
chances that Jesus walked this exact
road are 100% not 90% 95% 100% because
this is the road that everybody took to
go toward the Temple Mount so when it
talks in the New Testament about Jesus
overturning money tables the
moneylenders along this is the road that
they're talking about right now the Via
della Rossa and none of that stuff we're
talking about the actual places where
Jesus walked and for a thousand years
before people were walking hundreds of
years before people were walking they've
uncovered seals with names on them in
ancient Hebraic script that are the
exact names that are mentioned in turn
off that are mentioned in the in the
prophets it's an amazing amazing thing
here's a little bit of video in case you
can see it of what the of what some of
this looks like so you can see this is
all antiquities that have been uncovered
these are thousands of years old one of
the fun things about coming to Jerusalem
so when you're in the United States NIV
is an ancient place in the United States
maybe this is a Gettysburg that's like
150 years old maybe you go visit
Independence Hall that's 230 years old
maybe and then you come to Israel and
you're visiting places that are 3,000
years old you're walking on the same
exact pathways that were walked by
people a 2000 years ago 2500 years ago
when people deny the Judaic nature of
the origins of this land they are just
denying history and the City of David
proves it full-scale and we are talking
about we are talking about Jewish
occupancy of the Land of Israel fully
2,000 years before the rise of Islam so
when people when the UN when the UN
declares that the Old City of Jerusalem
is Islamic territory that is insane okay
I'm sorry that's insane
if you're declaring then they've tried
to stop a lot of the digging for
Antiquities specifically because they
don't like the Jewish connections to
these places the the Palestinian
Authority has famously urged these
ilanic walks on the Temple Mount to
actually dig up and destroy Antiquities
on the Temple Mount in order to prevent
the Jews from claiming that the Temple
Mount is Jewish the Obama administration
and all of their horrific ridiculousness
about the State of Israel they actually
in the very late stages of the Obama
administration allowed a UN resolution
to go forward declaring that the Temple
Mount as well as the western wall or
occupied territory okay if you're
talking about the holiest
in Judaism that preexist Christianity by
a full thousand years in Islam by Poul
2,000 years if you're talked about that
is occupied Jewish territory it's
because you are deliberately ignoring
history the City of David proves it if
you're in Jerusalem you should totally
check it out it's a pretty amazing
experience
alrighty well we'll be back here next
week after the Jewish holidays I'm sure
I'm gonna miss a lot so when I come back
there will be a lot to talk about in the
meantime have yourself a wonderful
weekend or join us a little bit later
today for two additional hours I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 on the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation